شركه تويتر تشهد سقوطا حرا على مستوى
مداخل الاعلانات اخر الارقام المعلنه
بخصوص عائدات الاعلانات كانت صادمه بشكل
كبير فقد تراجعت عائده اعلانات تويتر في
الولايات المتحده بنحو 59 فذلك للاسابيع
الخمسه الاولى التي تلت بدايه شهر ابريل
وذلك نقلا عن صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
الامريكيه ومن غير المرجح ان يتحسن هذا
الاداء في اي وقت قريب نقلا عن مصادر
الصحيفه الامريكيه اما ايلون ماسك فقد برر
هذا التراجع بالضغط الشديد الذي يمارسه
المعلنون في اوروبا وامريكا الشماليه على
الشركه متهم اياهم بمحاوله دفع تويتر الى
الافلاس
الصحيفه حاولت رصد اسباب تراجع عائلتي
تويتر من الاعلانات وذكرت الصحيفه نقلا عن
موظفي مبيعات الاعلانات في تويتر ان
المعلنين باتوا يخشون من ارتفاع خطاب
الكراهيه على المنصه وتعد اعلانات تويتر
امرا بالغ الاهميه لتحقيق التوازن المالي
للشركه حيث ان مداخيل الاعلانات شكلت منذ
فتره طويله 90% من ارباح الشركه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات